we have another supreme court decision
from the current supreme court which is
by any stretch of the imagination an
activist supreme court it's a supreme
court whose interpretation of freedom of
religion
is the freedom to impose religion
and it just so happens it's always some
form of christianity or some
some some version of someone's belief
about what christianity is
on to others what is the decision that
i'm talking about the supreme court is
backing a coach
who prays on the field after games this
is a story we talked about when it
happened and when it became an issue and
when the prayer at the school became an
issue and it has now found its way all
the way up to the supreme court and we
now have a decision the associated press
reports the supreme court said monday
yesterday
a high school a football coach who knelt
and prayed on the field after games
was protected by the constitution a
decision that opponents said would open
the door to quote much more coercive
prayer in public schools absolutely and
we will talk about that the court ruled
six to three for the coach with the
conservative justices and the majority
the liberals in the dissent this was the
latest in a line of rulings for
religious plaintiffs listen when you put
a it's
sometimes we just miss the forest for
the trees or we don't see what's right
in front of us or whatever metaphor
analogy you want to use
we have one of the most
right-wing christian supreme courts in a
long time
and they are ruling for the imposition
of christianity that's i mean that
that's the bottom line
the case forced the justices to wrestle
with how to balance the religious and
free speech rights of teachers and
coaches with the right of students not
to feel pressured into participating in
religious practices the liberal justices
and the minorities said there was
evidence that bremerton high school
coach joseph kennedy's prayers at the
50-yard line had a coercive effect on
students and allowed him to incorporate
his personal religious beliefs into a
school event the the coach is christian
after the games he would lead prayer at
the 50-yard line now the liberal
justices said there's a coercive aspect
to it
on students there's a power dynamic of
course
dissenting justice sonia sotomayor wrote
that this the decision sets us further
down a perilous path in forcing states
to entangle themselves with religion why
states well because this is a public
school it is a state-run school and
therefore it is in a sense state
government
when you look at an image
of what the prayer looked like
you can see that this is an
establishment of the prayer this is not
i mean you for people who aren't
watching you've got the coach
and the prayer circle of players around
him
and then media around that taking
pictures you're telling me there's no
coercive effect
for
the the player who would rather be
outside of the circle the one the the
two players who say yeah i'm opting out
of this you're saying there's no
reasonable feeling if you're one of the
players that well i'm not being forced
but i'm sort of stigmatizing myself if i
say i'm gonna opt out of this dog and
pony show of course not and that's the
point
that sonia sotomayor was making
on the other hand uh back to the
associated press article the justices
and the majority emphasized the coach's
prayers came after the games were over
and at a time when he was no longer
responsible for students and was free to
do other things
come on guys
come on the stu so because the game ends
now that there's no more coercive impact
there's no more power dynamic well the
game's technically over so now what the
coach is doing with the vast majority of
the players has no impact on me
no
the coach and his attorneys at first
liberty institute a christian legal
group were among those cheering the
decision kennedy said his first reaction
was pure joy
judge neil gorsuch writing for the
majority declared the constitution and
the best of our traditions counsel
mutual respect and tolerance not
censorship and suppression for religious
and non-religious views alike
but when this is what the coach is
establishing
the coach is very clearly setting
religious views above non-religious
views
so
gorsuch also noted the coach prayed
during a period where school employees
were free to speak with a friend
call for a reservation at a restaurant
check email or attend to other personal
matters while students were otherwise
occupied this is yet another this is the
latest completely improper decision
from it's a right-wing christian court
deciding for right-wing christianity now
do any of us believe
that if this was the situation
but the coach were
muslim
or the coach were
a satanist or whatever the case may be
that the entire religious community
would see this the exact same way i mean
would even the very christians
applauding this decision see it the same
way they would say of course not they
would be saying it's this is pushing
muslim beliefs this is pushing
satanic beliefs on the students the
students are the students they are at a
power disadvantage this is completely
improper the coach is in a position of
authority the coach controls who gets to
play the coach controls who makes the
team the following year the players will
feel pressured to engage in the prayer
so as not to anger the coach it's
implicit that the coach decides who
makes the cut who gets to play
and so when the coach says join me in
prayer but it's just optional you can go
and check email if you want or walk away
the pressure is there and sonia
sotomayor is 100 correct that it is
coercive all he has to do is say we're
going to pray now
and because of the dynamic it's the same
as if it was in a science classroom
okay if in a science classroom the
biology teacher says we're going to pray
now oh but by the way i mean listen it's
just optional i'm going to pray and most
of us are going to pray but you don't
have to uh the power imbalance is the
implied pressure
the coaches have more power than the
athletes the teachers have more power
than the students this is the way it is
and unfortunately this is not going to
be the final decision the last decision
that goes this way with this supreme
court if you disagree with me let me
know
we have a headline
that is scaring many in our audience
one million voters have switched to the
republican party does this spell
disaster for the upcoming 2022 midterms
well let's think about it
these are the most important midterms in
a long time now if you've been watching
the show for a while you know i am not
hyperbolic with the importance of any
particular election i've said this
before in 2012 when mitt romney was
challenging barack obama's re-election i
supported barack obama i didn't support
mitt romney i believed obama was the
better choice but there was no feeling
at least for me
that the future of the country was
riding on that yeah i agreed more with
obama than romney romney would have
lowered taxes for the rich and would
have done other things i don't agree
with in his social views as a
conservative mormon or not my views but
it was not the most important election
of our time
the 2014 midterm
um it was
not the most important election of our
time and i didn't call it that at the
time
i can't remember a more important
midterm than the 2022 midterm and so
when we now see these headlines more
than one million voters switch to the
republican party in a warning for
democrats it is a concerning and
disturbing headline now yesterday we
talked about on the one hand it seems as
though democrats actually have some
pretty reasonable um
they have a reasonable case to make with
two issues the overturning of roe v wade
and the um unwillingness and disinterest
from republicans in acting on gun safety
legislation democrats have some
powerful things to run on if voters
still care about them in four and a half
months that's good for democrats on the
other hand what about this
a political shift is beginning to take
hold writes the associated press tens of
thousands of suburban swing voters who
helped fuel the democratic party's gains
are becoming republicans
more than a million voters across 43
states have switched to the republican
party over the last year according to
data analyzed by the ap
the previously unreported number
reflects a phenomenon playing out in
virtually every region of the country
democratic and republican states along
with cities and small towns in the
period since joe biden replaced trump
nowhere is the shift more pronounced and
dangerous for democrats than in the
suburbs where well-educated swing voters
who turned against trump's republican
party in recent years are swinging back
swinging back
far more people switching to the
republican party in counties from denver
to atlanta pittsburgh and cleveland
republicans also gaining ground in
medium-sized cities such as harrisburg
pennsylvania raleigh north carolina
augusta georgia and des moines iowa now
what does this mean
well on the one hand we have to
understand that the united states is a
country plagued by ignorance the country
is plagued by ignorance so you see
very clear differences democrats not
nearly liberal or left-wing enough for
me but at least connected to reality on
fundamental issues of science of reality
to some degree about economic justice
it's not a perfect party of course i
have so many complaints about the
democratic party but at least connected
to reality on the republican side
particularly as trumpism has has taken
over
there has been this plague of ignorance
which is not only present it's
celebrated and you'll see some clips
later in the show that remind us of this
and uh it is not a shock in that sense
that we are seeing
voters to some degree fall for joe biden
did high gas prices joe biden did
inflation
joe biden is responsible for what's
happening in ukraine or whatever the
case may be and that they would say well
i guess i'll abandon the democratic
party and vote for republicans it
doesn't make any sense when we think
about it it seems completely backwards
but that's not a shock but there's a
couple of caveats with this voter
registration shift that i think are are
important to keep in mind one is there
are many libertarians that are becoming
republicans
and so
there's a difference between a democrat
becoming a republican
and a libertarian becoming a republican
libertarians in the united states tend
to vote with the republican party anyway
the american libertarian movement is
pretty right-wing and so if you take
this would sort of be like i'm an
independent voter i'm i'm unregistered
i'm not a democrat or a republican if i
were to announce to you i am now
becoming a democrat if a million people
like me said i'm now a democrat
does it really change anything about the
outcome of elections because i mostly
vote for democrats anyway i just don't
care about the democratic party it's not
if i'm going to be a member of something
i want to do that
uh enthusiastically i have no enthusiasm
for the democratic party as a party so
i'm just an independent and i vote for
democrats if a million people like me
become democrats doesn't really make a
difference and so of those million
um i don't have the exact numbers but a
bunch of them are libertarians who are
mostly right-wing and vote for
republicans or don't vote at all
becoming republicans and it doesn't
necessarily mean that the balance is
going to shift the other caveat is that
this study about the million voters
becoming republicans this was before the
gun rights discussion that has surfaced
after a number of school shootings and
mass shootings and this is before the
supreme court overturned roe v wade and
so
while we can believe the data that the
data this is good data the data is real
there's the libertarian element that i
mentioned which is a caveat and there's
also we don't know yet what the full
effect of roe v wade being overturned
and the anger about republican
unwillingness to deal with with gun
safety that is not yet part of the
polling so is it a good sign for 22 no
it's not a good sign but it doesn't have
to be the disastrous sign that some are
making it out to be that's my
interpretation let me know yours you can
find me on twitter at deepakman we're
going to take a quick break and be back
right after this we have seen a very
interesting turn of events over the last
few days this lawyer john eastman he's
the guy who wrote the memo to donald
trump saying here's how mike pence could
overturn the election
there's a question as to whether eastman
really believed that that was a viable
way to overturn the election or knew it
would be against the law and this has
become a very central issue in the
january sixth committee
eastman has now appeared on tucker
carlson
saying that the fbi seized his phone
last week there is video of the fbi
seizing his phone last week and to many
of us this doesn't come as a surprise
because supposedly this other attorney
hershman testified
the other attorney eric hirschman
testified
that he told eastman you need a criminal
defense attorney for what you've done
here so we're going to go through all of
it but for starters here is tucker
carlson very very angry
showing the video of eastman having his
phone seized by the fbi now critically
and illegally they seized his phone
before they presented him with a warrant
and it's on tape watch
so we're going to put your arms off for
me can i put your charms up for me
i'd like to see the warrant before you
take my property
[Applause]
i want you to see
that they took my property before
providing me with the warrant
i'd like to read the wall okay now i
have to tell you i am as for due process
as anyone else if they didn't have a
warrant i would be saying this is an
absolute travesty of justice i spoke to
a couple of criminal defense attorneys
and they said you know this is really
sort of a technicality
the concern is the reason you grab the
phone and then show the warrant
is he could smash the phone okay if you
say he you don't
here's the warrant take your time to
read it in a second he grabs the phone
throws it on the ground and crushes it
and destroys evidence now would that be
a crime yes but if the evidence is gone
the evidence is gone so criminal defense
attorney attorneys told me this is not
we just show up and steal a phone if law
enforcement shows up and steals a phone
they have the warrant they wanted to
secure the phone they show the warrant
and the warrant of course was for the
phone and that's it so
in sp i'm not a lawyer in speaking to
lawyers they said this is this is not
the travesty of justice that tucker
carlson is making it out to be
so then tucker carlson invites eastman
and eastman says that by seizing the
phone it's also a crime because he has
privileged communications with clients
on the phone this warrant is invalid on
its face
but more importantly and i think this is
extremely important the the authority to
seize all of my information in modern
modern smartphones that's access to all
my private financial records i'm an
attorney it's access to all my
privileged communications with nearly
100 different clients that i have
currently
this stuff this stuff
is what we used to call a general
warrant that the british king issued to
just go rummage through somebody's
belongings to see if they could find
evidence of some crime the very reason
we have the fourth amendment is to
prevent that kind of abuse it's very
weird because he's a lawyer but he seems
to misunderstand so many things his
argument it almost sounds like you can
never seize the phone of a lawyer
lawyers use phones to communicate with
clients if you can never
seize
a phone if it has client communications
it's almost like you can never
investigate a lawyer i mean this this is
the way investigations work
and of course the handling of the
privileged information is a different
matter but is is this guy really this
dumb now any of us who have been paying
attention to this would have anticipated
that this would have happened here is
attorney eric hirschman who for the
january 6 committee described speaking
to john eastman and saying what you need
to do is get yourself a criminal defense
attorney for what you're doing he's been
i don't remember why he called me and he
or he texted me or called me
want to talk with me and he said he
couldn't reach others
and he started to
ask me about
something dealing with georgia and
preserving something potentially for
appeal
and
i said to him
are you out of your f in mind
right i said i
said i only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth for now on
orderly transition
you know the screamer said i don't want
to hear any other fn words coming out of
your mouth no matter what other than
orderly transition repeat those words to
me
eventually you said orderly transition
i said good john now i'm gonna give you
the best free legal advice you're ever
getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're gonna need it right so
we all of course have been expecting
this to happen
and indeed now it did now here's the
cherry on top tucker carlson you know
just lionizing this guy who came up with
an illegal way to try to prevent joe
biden from becoming president
tucker says if you're not a biden voter
you should regularly be purging your
phone of all of your text messages and
emails because they could be coming for
you
the very reason we have the fourth
amendment is to prevent that kind of
abuse and yet that's what they're doing
here
and it's just another reminder to anyone
who didn't vote for joe biden to erase
your texts and emails every single day
and that is a sincere piece of advice i
hope everyone follows but they haven't
charged you with a crime they've given
you no evidence that they're going to
charge you with a crime but they treat
you like a drug kingpin or a rapist
and seize your phone
is this legal
i don't think so and yeah uh it's it it
appears that it is actually legal so
there's tucker carlson recommending
clear your phone of all texts and emails
every day
if you didn't vote for joe biden these
people live in a fantasy world but it is
a dangerous fantasy world where their
delusions have real world impact we
expect that at some point the eastman
was going to be under fire legally and
it appears that he now is we will follow
it i want to follow up on yesterday's
discussion about
will they imprison women who seek
abortions and will they imprison or
attempt to imprison doctors who perform
abortions abortion has become a criminal
act in the state of south dakota uh
south dakota the governor of south
dakota is christie gnome christy gnome
is a big trump tool a big trump suck-up
brown-noser and uh i want to focus in on
this question
of going after abortion doctors she did
a number of interviews on sunday pieces
of which we looked at yesterday but i
want to focus in on this issue of
imprisoning doctors now in multiple
interviews christy gnome went out of her
way to say
we're not going to prosecute women when
it comes to abortion although she left
the possibility open if women went to a
different state where abortion is legal
and then come back to south dakota that
was a little scary yesterday but she is
making clear there seems to be a
significant appetite in south dakota to
go after legally the doctors performing
abortions let's take a look at this
first clip from face the nation on
sunday america has the worst maternal
mortality rate of any developed country
what specifically are you doing for
these women who not just when they have
the baby but during their pregnancy are
you giving them paid leave are you
giving them more health care rights in
your state are you giving them more
state funding what exactly are you doing
to keep them alive during their
pregnancy
you know i think that will be a lot of
the debate that will go on now in every
different state now that the supreme
court has made this decision the power
but she's not asking about the debate
she's asking what are you doing in south
dakota or to make these decisions really
goes to each individual state we've
already talked about that in south
dakota what's the state's role in this
and what can we do to help these
individuals that are in these situations
get them the health care that they need
to to help their baby be born healthy
and help them be parents or help them
choose a loving family to raise that so
a non-answer okay so you're still
figuring out the specifics
okay well and you know this trigger law
was put into place years ago uh and it
was to go into it
into law as soon as the supreme court
made a decision such as it did so okay
that's the debate and discussion that
we're having but i think what's
incredible and what's going on is that
the people will decide you know elected
officials at the state level is who
they'll be talking to to decide what
their state's laws look like south
dakota's uh obviously uh you know under
our past several years and have stood
for life and defending life and i think
we'll continue to have those debates on
how we can support these mothers and
what it means to really make sure that
we're not prosecuting mothers ever in a
situation like this when it comes to
abortion that it will always be focused
towards those doctors who knowingly
break the law to perform abortions in
our state the criminal charges will be
focused on the doctors the doctors
she then appeared on this week and again
she said if doctors knowingly break the
law they should indeed be prosecuted
let's take a look and what about
medication abortions the the so-called
abortion pill how will you know if women
receive those in the mail and should
those women be prosecuted
i don't believe women should ever be
prosecuted i don't believe that mothers
in this situation never be prosecuted
now doctors who knowingly violate the
law they should be prosecuted definitely
and the pill is okay you're saying the
pill is okay
again martha you're interrupting but i
am answering your question i don't
believe that that telemedicine abortions
are safe for individuals for women to
conduct at home many times they're doing
it unsupervised it's a medical procedure
and so i do believe that there should be
a physician supervision in place when
that is being conducted by any
individual all right so they're going to
go after the doctors and they do seem to
sort of be cohering around this talking
point remember that early in trumpism
they weren't totally clear on do you
punish the women because there was this
time trump was asked about do you punish
the women and trump said yes do you
believe in punishment for abortion yes
or no as a principle and the answer is
that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form ten cents ten years
there you go and of course afterwards
trump was told no no no that's the wrong
talking point we don't say that we say
punish the doctors and by the next day
trump was saying no no i didn't mean i
didn't mean punish the women i didn't
mean that i mean punish the doctors now
um two states so far minnesota and
massachusetts have seen their governors
sign orders protecting providers who
perform abortions for out-of-state
residents and that's one aspect of this
the governors of minnesota and
massachusetts have implemented legal
protections for reproductive health care
providers
who serve out-of-state out-of-state
residents who come to their state
seeking such care
uh that's one aspect of this but this is
sort of a different question which is
what about circumstances where you have
in-state everything is in state what is
it that is going to be the goal of these
extreme right-wing states so this is
increasingly looking very much like you
know a market margaret atwood book quite
frankly that's what it is looking like
and uh it is scary stuff that we are
going to continue tracking but it is not
looking particularly good hey this is
wild uh this crazy trumpest republican
candidate carrie lake
she lost it when fox news's brett bayer
confronted her about her hypocrisy on
drag queens now
in case you don't know about drag queens
drag queens are typically we're talking
about male performers
who use what's called drag clothing and
makeup to imitate and sometimes even
exaggerate
female gender signifiers
but it's entertainment purposes
drag queens are not trans people you
might have trans drag queens but when we
talk about drag queens we're talking
about sort of like a performance uh
thing we're not talking about
um uh transgender people okay fine so
carrie lake
has been uh viciously going after
drag queens and people who enjoy drag
queens and all these different things
and it turns out that uh a drag queen
came out and said i've performed for
carrie lake carrie lake has hired drag
queens to perform multiple times she's a
hypocrite okay so she goes on fox news
bret bayer confronts her she didn't
expect to be confronted about this on
fox news and she flips out it says
arizona gop candidate who criticized
drag queens was once a fan according to
a drag queen this is the quote arizona
gop gubernatorial way it's obviously so
stupid what's going on but she is a
hypocrite and good for bret baer for
asking her about it and carrie lake who
has attacked drag queens as dangerous to
children attended the shows of drag
queen richard stevens for more than 20
years and once hired him to perform at
her home do you care to address that i
do care i actually do care to address
that and i'm really shocked
i'm actually appalled
that fox news would take defamatory
story like that and we are pursuing
legal action against this drag queen sue
the drag queen i'm appalled that you
would bring that up when you have not
talked about or stolen election you
failed you spent three questions mr lake
talking about this i just asked you a
number of questions about it i played
the arizona this is the first city let's
address let's address this story that's
in the washington post every candidate
takes tough stories i'm asking you to
respond to it if you'd like to i'm happy
to address it but i'm really
disappointed in fox i thought you were a
little better than cnn i'm really
disappointed
this is a person who i covered for
decades for decades 20 years
and he's never been in my home he says
he's been in my home for a drag show
that's ludicrous he's never been in my
home he's lied we tried to serve him
defamation papers okay and he's so shady
that we can't even track him down
because he's not even welcome at the
place
i'm sorry but this is the last question
i'm going to ask what about these
pictures of you with him
isn't that the best what about the
pictures where you're together richard
stevens
what about this is the post i've
performed for carrie's birthday i've
performed in her home i've performed for
her at some of the seediest bars in
phoenix i don't want to ask these
questions i ask you to address them
actually i think i think you do want to
ask them but you don't want to ask about
2000 mules right i think ganesh de souza
film dude that's the real issue guys do
you want to ask about this
this is absolutely ludicrous i'm i'm
talking about drag shows in schools this
is what triggered this man somebody who
goes to a drag show with female
impersonators is one thing we don't want
our tax money going into drag shows at
school okay i understand what you're
making a difference there but you're
saying his allegations are wrong is what
you're saying
yes i am all right
despite the pictures the allegations are
completely untrue
unhinged unhinged and this is what it
has come down to folks these people are
out of their minds and they might win in
november
if we don't get out and vote we'll have
these clips on our instagram find us on
instagram at david pakman show
it is great to have back on the program
bobby azarian who's a cognitive
neuroscientist blogger for psychology
today and whose new book is the romance
of reality how the universe organizes
itself to create life consciousness and
cosmic complexity bobby great uh
speaking to you again
thanks for having me back david so i
mean the book is fascinating because it
starts with these are just big topics
right how what what are the origins of
life what is what is consciousness what
is sort of our place how do we
understand our ability to perceive and
understand but it also has very much
real world kind of day-to-day
nitty-gritty implications about how we
solve individual problems political
questions how people relate to each
other how we understand what is real and
what is not real and kind of
epistemology can you talk just like
generally what was the main point you
wanted to get across in the book
so yeah there are a lot of points that
you mentioned uh but the general idea is
that uh
so it's i guess to contrast it to the
old paradigm the old paradigm uh the
kind of reigning scientific worldview
was known as the reductionist paradigm
and it basically says that life is
something of a cosmic accident and that
life is transient and has no larger
cosmic significance
but the story that's emerging from
complexity science is challenging that
basically says that the universe isn't
getting increasingly disordered as once
thought it's getting more and more
complex
and life is a part of that uh
complexification process and once life
emerges it becomes the driver of that
process
so uh we're not an accident we are a
natural manifestation of the laws of
physics and the evolutionary dynamics
that emerge from those laws
and this means that life has something
like a purpose
in the universe and that's to see that
life continues to persist and spread
throughout the cosmos
so what's fascinating about that to put
to pause there is
if people listen to 90 but not 100 of
what you're saying
they might misunderstand what you're
saying as meaning either one
that there is
purpose in the way that some attribute
to religion or god which is not what
you're saying here you're saying that
the purpose of life is is to persist
life wants to continue so so to speak
and number two if people listen to 90
but not 100 of what you're saying they
might think you're saying that the
pre-existing ideas for example about
entropy are being contradicted by what
you're saying but you're not really
you're you're sort of
expanding on that uh in a sense if i
understand correctly
yeah so to address those two points uh
let's start with the entropy point first
uh there's a lot of confusion about what
the second law of thermodynamics means
yes and uh there's a statistical
interpretation of that law that
basically says that ordered systems will
naturally move
toward a more disordered state
and uh that that's true for closed
systems so closed systems are systems
that aren't open to energy coming in
from an outside source
so the planet earth is an open system
and that is because we have a star we
have our sun
that is radiating all this energy down
on the planet and those energy flows
uh basically uh organize
life
and uh we so
energy flowing through a simple chemical
system will organize it and that is the
mechanism that creates life
on a planet so the idea
basically is that life can continue to
persist against this tendency towards
disorder as long as it can continue to
extract energy from the environment
because the energy is used to sustain
itself
but uh in using that energy uh it uses
up ordered energy and it dissipates that
energy as heat and that creates entropy
too so complexity can grow and grow and
grow if life can spread and find more
energy and the second law of
thermodynamics really just says that
there's an energetic cost to creating
order that you have to use some of this
available energy and
basically turn that energy into entropy
so it doesn't violate the second law
unless you think the second law
applies to the whole universe and says
that the universe is growing
increasingly disordered this challenges
that and says we need to understand that
entropy is this complex term it takes on
a number of forms
and that life uh doesn't have to be
transient if we can
solve our problems
and continue
to extract energy
then
we can persist
the religious purpose that is often
debated by
christian apologists and others
you're talking about purpose in a
different way and and it makes intuitive
sense if you think about for example um
uh
evolution right and the idea well when
we when we talk about purpose you could
say the purpose here is evolution is
fueling
more fit species so that they can
continue to live so that life persists
as you're talking about we don't have to
talk about purpose ideologically
necessarily or as a designed thing and
still acknowledge that maybe purpose
could be an appropriate word in terms of
life wanting to preserve and continue
yes so uh there was
a big movement to kind of get purpose
out of biology in the 20th century right
but we're understanding that uh purpose
or agency uh is really the defining
characteristic of life so if you compare
life to an inanimate object like a rock
or a chair those things don't do
anything interesting and if they move if
a rock
you know
tumbles down a hill it's because of the
force of gravity or if you see a rock
moving on the street it's being pushed
by a gust of wind but life uh moves uh
according to survival goals
so it has agency and this agency is
basically
a product of the information stored in
living systems which are adaptive
systems
so uh it's really helpful to talk about
purpose but if you zoom out and you look
at the universe and you understand that
life uh isn't any sort of uh magical
uh it doesn't have some sort of magical
ingredient propelling it then you see
that uh the inanimate matter in the
universe is waking up uh in the form of
life and so you don't see it so much as
just life trying to persist you see it
as the universe sort of waking up uh
through life and being able to
experience itself
so there are some big uh what i would
call spiritual implications of this
theory
but it is an entirely mechanistic
naturalistic picture because we can
understand these uh processes that
generate complexity
we can formalize them with mathematics
so
there's no magic in this framework
however i will say it is still really
mysterious why the universe is so
fine-tuned
to give rise to life and if you uh
believe the argument in this book
it doesn't just allow life it
necessitates life and basically ensures
that life will continue to adapt and
spread
so now in in along those lines
when we look at societies and the way
that
human society is organized we can find
lots of relatively persistent you know
i'm talking here about hundreds of years
which is still a real relatively small
amount of time but but it's modern
society we see lots of mechanisms that
seem like they would run counter to that
right uh world wars for example um the
seeking and obtaining of nuclear weapons
which you know it's hard to argue that
nuclear weapons in some long-term way
will preserve life they seem only only
able to potentially destroy it or at
best do do nothing at all
conflict
what is the role
at the sort of more medium-term society
level of some of these systems that seem
to run very contrary to to life
so there's a principle in the book uh
that i call poppers principle named
after the philosopher of science karl
popper and it basically says that
problems create progress
so you mentioned world war ii and it was
a terrible time a lot of bad things
happened but that same time period
produced the computer and information
technology and the computer was kind of
a need uh to do a couple of things uh
people have seen a movie about alan
turing where the computer was used to
crack uh enigma the nazi code yep and uh
the computer was also used
to try to create uh
nuclear weapons
um by von neumann and others uh so you
do get this kind of paradoxical thing
where
you have technology that has uh terrible
uses and really good uses
so
it does seem um a little bit
contradictory but not when you realize
that it's the problems that we face
that pushes us to find solutions and
pushes us in the direction of progress
mass extinctions uh basically if you
look at the the the trend uh as far as
like biological complexity and diversity
after every mass extinction uh the
biosphere went to new levels of
complexity and diversity so
it's like uh life adapts and evolves and
evolves uh because it has challenges so
uh this will lead people to kind of
question this uh idea of progress
because they you know see all these
things going on these mounting
existential challenges like climate
change and the threat of nuclear war
rising income inequality uh but it is
precisely those challenges
that uh push us to uh
find solutions that ultimately lead to
progress now that doesn't mean
we ignore the like so for example
someone might hear that and say hey
listen based on what bobby said
we just shouldn't worry about climate
change because even if it is as
destructive as the worst hypotheses say
it is
eventually life will persist and things
will just kind of like reorder
themselves and everything will be okay
but it sounds like what you're saying is
these are opportunities for humans to do
things and to figure out solutions
yes so that thing that you said earlier
would be like the the the worst way to
interpret this yes uh we can't the
process doesn't happen on its own and it
goes back to
uh the point that we're part of this
process yes so we need to try uh our
very best to overcome these solutions if
not we will be
the errors that get corrected by natural
selection and the people who come after
us or the uh you know species or
civilization that comes after us
uh will uh do something different uh
hopefully they'll learn from our
mistakes but yeah it's this process of
continually
learning from failure right and uh yeah
we
have to do everything in our power to
overcome these existential challenges
and uh one thing that this uh theory uh
kind of um shows about society is that
societies work in a very similar way
as organisms organisms biological
organisms so you are an organism and you
usually think about that as being one
single thing but you're a collective of
cells right working together in an
integrated fashion your brain is a
collection of 80 billion neurons all
connected by 10 000 connections each
and the
output of that collective computation is
your intelligent behavior and your
productivity so you can look at a
society as being a social organism and
you can even look at uh the network of
humans that spans the planet as forming
something like a global brain
because of the internet and social media
and now blockchain systems connecting us
in a very similar way
and
if we want to overcome our existential
challenges we have to use the full
computational power of the global brain
and this gives us some principles for
how to optimize
our social political and economic
systems so on that note in the limited
time we have left
all of this if we go down to kind of
like the nitty-gritty level
what are the immediate things that in
human society could be done
as you see it to better orient ourselves
towards this future and this could be
regulating social media passing some ru
laws about carbon i mean really like if
we just were to say what what are the
bullet points of things that could be
done
by governments and organizations at this
point to better serve our future is
there a sort of short list
uh yes uh there's a long list and a
short list so everything that you know
people are like fighting for right now
those are are you know worthy things
that uh we should be tackling but there
are some
more basic principles that come from
complexity science which just tells us
uh how to get the maximum amount of
computational power out of a system so
uh computational power is a function of
how complex a system is a system is more
complex if there are more components and
there are more connections between those
components and you also want a variety
of different types of components so
we want to be connected in you know a
way similar to how
neurons are connected in the brain
so
uh any nation that uh cuts their people
off from the internet is stopping that
free flow of information and the free
the free flow of information allows for
greater social awareness and knowledge
exchange
so you know countries like north korea
russia china that are doing that that's
not intrinsically good for a complex
adaptive system in the long run
the other thing i mentioned was the need
for diversity among components so the
human body
has over 200 cell types because they're
doing a division of labor a society of
all doctors or society of all engineers
or musicians uh wouldn't do well so we
need a specialization because it allows
for a division of labor
and uh we so we need diversity and not
just cultural diversity but a diversity
of ideas
so
any system any nation that doesn't allow
for criticism of the current system
that's also intrinsically bad because
you want new ideas that challenge the
status quo uh that's sort of how uh
progress happens too
um the last thing that i would say is uh
income inequality so we're seeing levels
of income inequality uh higher than
we've ever seen before
and that means all of the resources are
concentrated in these small pockets so
that would be so if society is a social
organism that would be like all of the
resources like the blood the nutrients
all
um in certain areas and not systemically
flowing right to all the appendages and
if that is the case
then uh ultimately that super organism
will die because those parts will fester
and then affect uh the rest of the body
so we want to uh
have a way to kind of redistribute these
resources i don't think like a communist
model or like a
socialist model is necessarily the best
way to do that because um you don't want
like a government with all this power
like calling the shots you want some
sort of uh natural
way to do that and um
i think the decentralization movement
made popular by cryptocurrencies and
bitcoin uh is a way to do that
because uh nfts will allow uh for a new
crowdfunding mechanism that will allow
you know normal people to
raise money for a business project and
then the people who are
uh donating to that project like they
would kickstarter they actually become
investors right um so there's a lot of
creative ways you know and
to think about how to structure society
maybe we need some optimal balance
between socialist and capitalist
policies uh decentralization could
provide you know new ideas about how to
find that balance
uh but yeah we need to look at how
nature has optimized systems through
evolutionary processes
uh
to kind of
teach us how to best optimize society
we've been speaking with cognitive
neuroscientist and blogger bobby azarian
the new book is the romance of reality
how the universe organizes itself to
create life consciousness and cosmic
complexity bobby always a pleasure
having you on
thank you so much david and
congratulations on being a new father
thank you
radical trumpist republican
congresswoman lauren bobert or beau bear
for those who prefer that pronunciation
our friend rokhana for example prefers
bo bear which i kind of i kind of like
it has a satirical ring to it um i uh
she has gone full theocracy she is
saying she's tired of this separation of
church and state junk she doesn't like
it now this is christian dominionism
this is radical christianity this is a
full fr full-fledged christian
nationalism and that is exactly what
congresswoman beaubert is proposing she
spoke you know as usual at some kind of
crazy
event in colorado i guess who even cares
it's these wild events
and um listen to what she had to say
about separation of church and state the
reason we had so many over-reaching
regulations in our nation is because the
church complied
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government wait a second
which church there's like a thousand
that's supposed to direct the church
that is not how our founding fathers
intended it and i'm tired of this
separation of church and state junk
that's not in the constitution it was in
a stinking letter and it means nothing
like what they say it does
[Music]
now
which church is supposed to direct the
government because
there are major differences between say
baptists and pentecostals and born-again
christians or evangelicals or catholics
or whatever never mind right like
jews muslims atheists okay
this is full-fledged christian
nationalism it's dystopian and it's
dangerous and most importantly it's not
true
all of the framers of the american
constitution understood
that no establishment meant no national
church no government involvement in
religion period that's it and they now
want to try for people who say that we
should go by the letter of what the
founders said
they sure want to do a bunch of
reinterpretation now as usual to just
fit whatever outcome they want today
thomas jefferson and james madison
believed
that unless you completely separate
religion and the state you don't really
have religious freedom it doesn't matter
whether the founders themselves were
theists or deists or christian or
whatever the case may be and often
people like lauren bober and others will
say
these were religious individuals and so
when they talked about all of these
things you have to sort of read between
the lines that they mean like this is a
christian country no no no no
they understood even for their own
religious freedom or that of anybody
else's
there is not really religious freedom
unless you separate church and state and
that means freedom
from and of religion and she's
complaining about overreaching
regulations
how is it that people who are worried
about being told
you have to separate church and state
are on the other hand okay
with the government telling people how
to make their own medical decisions how
can that be how can you simultaneously
say
there's too much government overreach in
trying to separate church and state and
just let everybody do whatever they want
privately
and leave religion out of government
okay that's too oppressive
but the government can come in and say
oh abortion no no we're going to decide
what medical procedures or lack thereof
are best for you and we're saying you
can't go and get it
there's a huge disconnect somewhere
between their ears and i think it's
because it's chocolate pudding that is
between their ears that seems to be
what's going on and uh
flippantly this church and state it's
sort of like if someone were to say
i'm so sick of this due process stuff
just throw them in jail just due process
a miranda a speedy trial
guys just throw them in prison that's
the equivalent of what she's saying i'm
so tired of the separation of church and
stage
everybody talking about this exhausting
freedom of speech just shut them up wait
wait but hold on it's part of the
framework on which this country i'm so
tired of it just throw it out dystopian
and this is what the country would
become if people like lauren beaubert
end up being in charge all right i don't
want to spend a ton of time on this many
of you emailed me about it this is
really funny newsmax host greg kelly is
calling out rudy giuliani and saying
dude you're claiming you got attacked
it seems like you're exaggerating so if
you haven't followed this story let me
back it up for you rudy giuliani was at
i guess it was like a shoprite
and
someone came up to rudy and kind of
patted him on the back and i guess said
something negative to him okay they
patted him on the back and rudy just
turned around and looked at them before
the video was out rudy was claiming that
he was hit it felt like a boulder that
it knocked him multiple steps forward he
thought it was i mean that it was just
like this crazy vicious physical attack
then the video came out and it becomes
very clear that it was not some guy
patted rudy on the back and said
something negative okay
rudy has doubled down and he keeps
talking about this assault and this is
so funny even cuckoo for coco puffs
right wing newsmax and its host greg
kelly says i gotta be honest rudy it
really doesn't look that bad so if
you're watching you'll actually see the
video of the i think they play the video
of the supposed assault check this out
i didn't know he was this good i really
didn't and his
uh his grasp of the by the way rudy's
audio plagued by background noise
particularly the issue of pride in the
economy
is remarkable
and the main thing that he has passion
tremendous passion hey mr mayor is
somebody mowing the lawn right outside
your window i can barely hear you yeah
we're at a big rally we're at a big
rally in staten island
right around the corner from where i was
attacked yesterday
we have that actually you were at a i
guess a delicate testing of some kind
i'm going to show the people what
happened and you tell me because let me
see the video if you don't mind uh
this person with the hand on your back
i gotta be honest it doesn't look that
bad but i i understand that looks can be
deceiving
you know that that was
that was the woman who was rubbing my
back not the guy who literally
you're watching
so the woman that woman uh
gave a statement to the police that the
guy hit me so hard that she herself
almost fell
yeah it's very clear that didn't happen
from the video the reverberation of it
she's a city the entire building echoed
from when rudy was patted on the back it
reverberated they were worried it was
going to break glass
there's a second grade detective
that that's that's the lady who uh
helped me oh all right good that makes
sense uh yeah um guys when greg kelly
from newsmax is saying you know it
really doesn't seem that bad
you might have gone a little bit too far
saying that it reverberated throughout
the reverberated throughout the building
can you imagine so okay so that's the
rudy thing i don't really want to talk
about it too much more but uh and of
course if if some if someone doesn't
want to be touched they shouldn't be
touched that's absolutely the case okay
so i'm not defending but it was like a
boulder it knocked me forward multiple
steps the guy patted rudy and rudy
turned to his left
that's all that happened okay so greg
kelly is not buying it we have a
voicemail number that number is
to david p
here is a really great question about
the recent medical drama
uh
that i talked about yesterday
including
the c-section birth of my daughter and
the re-hospitalization of my girlfriend
for a perforated uh duodenum duodenum
people were emailing me saying sorry
you're pronouncing it incorrectly
nuclear collaboration yeah i'm doing my
best with pronunciations anyway here's
an interesting question about the entire
thing
hey david i'm glad your girlfriend is
all right
but i have a question
i don't know what type of health
insurance you guys have because you run
an independent business correct but
how much did all this cost
so how much were you billed for um
the last time i went to the hospital
they charged me ten thousand dollars
to go five minutes down the street yep
fortunately though i was on medicaid at
the time so i didn't have to pay for any
of it this is a great question ma we
have not gotten any bills yet okay i do
plan to open up the books like i did
after my appendectomy you might remember
my appendectomy it was about 40 grand
of which i had to pay my two thousand
dollar deductible okay
so
um indeed both both of us are
self-employed and so we
buy insurance from our state's
marketplace when back during my
appendectomy when i was in massachusetts
i bought i had a plan i purchased
through what's called the mass health
connector new york state has a similar
thing through which we now have our
plans called my state of health these
are not the best plans okay so my
expectation is
that uh we are going to owe
the two thousand dollar deductible
for
the birth
and that associated hospital stay
the two thousand 000 deductible
for the re-hospitalization
for
the surgery
and then because of the ambulance call i
think that we probably have like a
man i don't it's probably a 500 co-pay
for the ambulance ride like these plan
these are not cheap plans and they also
cover very little
so that's what i expect to owe i think
our we're gonna owe somewhere between
four and five thousand dollars for all
of this i think the build amounts could
could probably get to 250 000
my understanding is that
c-section birth and subsequent
hospitalization
can be
80 grand or so and then um
the surgery plus like a six-day
hospitalization after that in
i think it's considered sub-acute care i
don't really know
that could be another that could be a
hundred grand 120 i think that the the
sort of sticker price on everything is
going to be somewhere around 200 000
could even be a little bit higher we
will see and i expect we will owe
somewhere around four or five thousand
so
i'll open the books when we get the
bills i haven't gotten them yet i'll
keep everybody posted we've got a great
bonus show for you today
uh with some horrible stories by the way
one positive thing is elizabeth warren
says democrats are only two votes away
from codifying roe v wade
is it too late well we'll talk about it
stacks of bodies have been found dead in
a trailer on the u.s mexico border
horrifying story and a study finds that
cannabis users are 25 percent more
likely to need emergency care
hospitalization but the question is is
it because of their cannabis use or is
it that people more likely to need
emergency care and hospitalization
are more likely to use cannabis which
would be a very very different
explanation all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad well i invite you to
sign up at joinpacman.com
get instant access to the david pakman
show bonus show thank your lucky stars
every day you're not dave pagman well
it's not that bad alex thank you very
much coupon code big voting 22
sign up at joinpacman.com i will see you
on the bonus show
you